- So, thank you so much for joining us
for Gaps in Health Equity,
Insights From History,
Lessons From COVID-19,
and Ideas for the Future.
This is the 10th in a series,
the Yale Development Dialogues,
which are virtual panel
discussions hosted by
Yale's Economic Growth Center,
Jackson Institute for Global Affairs
and History Department.
I'm Catherine Cheney.
I'm a Reporter at Devex
focused on technology and
innovation and global development.
And I really enjoy moderating
these conversations.
We bring together perspectives
from history, economics,
and policy to discuss
ways to address challenges
facing low and middle income countries.
And today we're joined by
experts who are leading voices
in understanding health and
healthcare challenges globally.
So, I have a number of
questions I'd like to ask them,
but for those of you
who are joining us Live
here on the Zoom webinar,
we really encourage you
to submit your questions
via the Q&A function.
And please don't wait until the very end
so that I can have a sense
of what you wanna hear
and make the conversation as
useful for you as possible.
Transitioning to the topic
that we're tackling today.
We all know that unequal
access to the COVID-19 vaccine
has magnified what are
really long standing gaps
in health equity.
And I found this
definition of health equity
from the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation
to be really useful in
preparing for this conversation.
So I'll share it with you.
"Health equity means
that everyone has a fair
and just opportunity to
be as healthy as possible.
This requires removing
obstacles to health,
such as poverty, discrimination
and their consequences,
including powerlessness and
lack of access to good jobs
with fair pay, quality
education and housing,
safe environments and healthcare."
So structural power inequities,
which the COVID-19 pandemic again,
has really highlighted results
in different health outcomes
based on factors that are
outside of people's control,
like where they were born.
In this webinar will
explore whether this crisis
will in fact, change the
conversation on health equity
and propel the kinds of
partnerships needed to achieve it.
We'll ask what lessons we can draw
from the COVID 19 pandemic
and from the past,
in order to design a
more equitable future.
I wanna quickly introduce our panelists
who can share more with us.
Today, I'm joined by Anne-Emanuelle Birn,
who's Professor of Critical
Development Studies
and of Social and
Behavioral Health Sciences
at the Dalla Lana School of Public Health
at University of Toronto.
Pascaline Dupas is the
Professor of Economics
at Stanford University
and Faculty Director
of the Stanford King Center
on Global Development,
which also has fantastic
events they've put on.
I highly recommend them.
Dr. Mesfin Teklu Tessema
is Head of the Health Unit
at the international Rescue Committee
and IRC Senior Leader in Health.
And Sunil Amrith is the Renu
and Anand Dhawan Professor
of History at Yale,
and one of three co-organizers
of the Yale Development Dialogue series
together with Rahini Pande, Rory Stewart.
Thanks so much to all
of you for joining us.
So, I wanna begin with you, Sunil.
I mean, you've really
championed this topic
as one that we should take on
as part of the Yale
Development Dialogue series,
bringing these different
perspectives together.
And I'd love for you to expand a bit on
why this topic and why now.
- Thank you, Catherine, and
thank you all for joining us.
Last year, when we started the
Yale Development Dialogues,
we were really in the
very midst of the pandemic
as we still are in many ways.
And we had a couple of very
successful conversations
on COVID, on COVID and
inequality, COVID and development.
And I think one of the messages
that was loud and clear
to me from those conversations was
this is only the beginning
of the conversation
that if anything, COVID has
highlighted just how deep rooted
inequities and health
are around the world.
As a historian, I've been very interested
in the history of moves
towards health equity,
both as a regional and a global scale.
And I think what we've seen is that
there are periods when there have been
substantive moves towards
a greater health equity.
You see this after the Second World War
where despite mass killing there was also
technological innovation and
process of decolonization
to the point where with
the foundation of the WHO
with the disease eradication campaigns
though they were flawed,
they were in some sense
profoundly democratizing
this was to go back to the definition
you gave us Catherine about
removing some of the obstacles
to the majority of the world's population
having better conditions of health.
See a very different
movement in the 1970s,
which is really coming
from the Global South.
And this is the movement that leads
to that very famous slogan,
"Health for all by the year 2000".
In the 2000s I think we see
a different type of movement
that kind of philanthropic movement
around the formation of
Garvey and the Global Fund.
Each of these movements has
its moment and of course,
we can talk about the
weaknesses within each of them,
which explains why
perhaps they didn't have
the impact that they intended to.
I think there are three questions
that come out of looking
at those histories though.
One is the question of accountability.
I think we always come
back to this question of
who's responsible for health equity?
Who has in a sense, the
right to make these decisions
about what will remove the obstacles
to the majority of the world,
having better access to
conditions of health?
The second is this constant push and pull
between a bottom up and
a top down approach.
One of the criticisms of the
disease eradication campaigns
of the 50s but also
some of the more recent
philanthropic efforts is that
they've been very top-down,
not really consultative,
not really responsive
to what people need in different
parts of the Global South.
And then the third question is,
how does one build political support
to make health equity a priority,
not just at the level
of global institutions,
but in each individual country
where this is a challenge.
and that includes right
here in the United States.
So I'm very keen to
hear from our panelists
who have such a diverse
range of expertise,
their perspectives on
all of these question.
- Thank you, Sunil.
Really helpful framing here.
And I appreciate your point that
we need to look to history
and evaluate what worked
and what didn't in each
of these movements.
Why didn't they have
their intended impacts?
We once talked about health
for all by the year 2000,
here we are in 2021.
And the sustainable development goals
are one of these frameworks looking at
really health for all by 2030.
Will we get there?
What will it take and what
can we learn from history?
So really helpful framing.
Building on what we can learn from history
I'd love to bring
Anne-Emanuelle into this.
So, your work focuses on the history
and politics of international
and global health,
mostly in Latin America.
And I wonder if you can
expand on lessons from history
when it comes to advancing health equity.
- Sure. And let me begin by saying that
I don't quite agree with the
notion of lessons from history.
I think that perspectives, shedding light,
contextualizing,
understanding are better ways
because the context always shifts, right?
So you can't have importable
or exportable lessons,
whether over time or over space,
just as some of the very
prescriptive top-down
health campaigns that Sunil was mentioning
are very fraught when Peru is
seen as the same as Thailand
is seen as the same as
Botswana, et cetera.
So I just wanted to put that
on the table to get us going.
- I appreciate that.
- And in terms of the Latin
American region historically,
I think we also need to consider
moments of advance progress,
but also enormous setbacks
not necessarily the same
or expected moments in time
in terms of international events.
So there's also very peculiar
or specific situations
in different regions.
And one issue has to do with the rise
of Social Security systems.
Actually fairly early on in
many Latin American countries
that were industrializing,
Chile as one of the prime examples.
And so there was an early
Social Security system
in 1924 set up, but it was exclusive to
urban industrial workers,
not even their families were included.
And so you had this step forward,
but then the exclusion
of indigenous people,
of rural peoples, et cetera, et cetera.
And then you have another wave in the...
Well, expectation of
wave in the late 1930s
when the popular front is elected
and Salvador Allende becomes
Chile Minister of Health.
And yet the expectation of setting up
a universal healthcare
system fails because
it gets embroiled in some of
the anticommunist ideology
and pressures in the 1940s.
So you really have these waves.
Then in the 1950s, the
leftists are out of government
and they do manage to put a
universal healthcare system
in place with certain flaws
and exclusions and so on.
And so we need to think
about this heterogeneity
as well as kind of narrative flipping,
which I'm always concerned
with this idea that
countries of the Global
South are following,
are learning in the Bismarckian Model
or the British National
Health Service Model.
In fact, Chileans would argue the opposite
that the Brits just got faster
to the legislative sausage
making than the Chileans did.
But also the importance
of not having nostalgia
for the past.
So, no society has ever
reached perfect health equity.
It's always a process, right?
And so even countries that
have made enormous strides,
such as Cuba have been slower
in some realms than others.
I mean, they've worked
very hard to bring in
rural folks and prioritizing rural folks,
but rather later at bringing LGTBQIA folks
having their health needs covered.
So I think there's kind of
a wide heterogeneity there
that we need to be mindful
of when looking at history
and thinking through those perspectives.
- Yes, I really appreciate the nuance
you've brought to this.
Both that no country has
reached perfect health equity,
it's always a process.
And that you can't have these
importable exportable
lessons context matters.
I think that's really valuable.
Thank you.
I wanna bring Pascaline into this.
So your research has focused on questions
related to health equity.
There are many examples of this
one being for example,
why there hasn't been more investment
in fighting neglected diseases.
And I wonder if you can expand
on some of your research
and some of your findings most relevant
to this topic of health equity.
- So my own research is not so much about
why some pieces are neglected
I think we know exactly
why they are neglected.
It's just a matter of like
economics, unfortunately,
which is that all of the diseases
that are specific to really poor countries
the pharmaceutical companies
would have the incentives
to do R&D, well there's no incentive there
because the very people
who need this medicine,
all these vaccines cannot
afford to pay for them.
And they can't afford to
pay very much for them.
And their governments cannot afford
to pay very much for them.
Unfortunately where the economics
versus health comes into play.
So my own work has been sitting here well,
given that there's no vaccine for Malaria,
given that there's not much investments
in this negative diseases,
what can be done in the meantime?
And they have some term like how do we say
coping strategies.
There are antimalarial bed
nets that you can sleep under
in order to protect
yourself and your children.
And so trying to understand
what are the barriers
to every household in
a malaria epidemic area
having access to that is
what I've been working on.
But over the years what
I've realized is that
there are so many of these issues
that poor households in poor
countries have to deal with.
There's a bed net for Malaria.
There is making sure that your
water is not contaminated.
There's making sure that
you have enough iodine
because your salt is not iodized
and also stuff like that.
And so the honors is really on the people
to take so many actions
to cope with the fact that
their environment is not safe.
And to me, it's not sustainable.
So going back to the definition
you just gave us, Catherine
that no one of the key
factor is safe environment.
And to me, the biggest
source of health inequity
in the world is really
between higher income
and lower income countries.
And it comes a lot from the difference
in the safety and the environment.
The fact that there are
some tropical diseases
or some issues with environment
that that households
cannot subject to in a way,
unless we try to tackle those
big environmental factors,
we are not gonna get equity in any way
if we think of it from the point of view
of across countries, not
just within the countries.
And so in as much as I'm
sympathetic to Sunil's complain
about top-down apertures
not being well-tailored,
I do think that for these
huge environmental concerns,
we actually need top down,
because it's really about
coming up with the technologies,
coming up with vaccines,
getting the international
resources together
to get these vaccines out.
And it's not something
that at the middle level
I don't have much as the poor country.
I don't have any leverage
to make that happen.
And so why the disease
or inefficient campaign
after World War II did not go as far as
one would have wished.
I'm gonna leave you on
this story Anne in the room
to speak to that.
But I do think it's
important to try to go back
to this and to really
not forget about this.
It originates in the
environment that people face.
And within my own discipline economics,
I think over the last 10, 15, 20 years
has been kind of pushed
back against this sentiment
that geography matters.
It's all about institutions.
And just to bring your
geography back onto the table,
because I do think it's
a very important factor.
- Really, really helpful.
And I wanna get back into our
conversation as we all jump in
about this debate over
geography institutions,
what are the structures
that lead to this inequity?
We need to sort that
out before we figure out
how to tackle it.
I also really appreciated
you talking about
really what this is
like at household level,
covering global health and
international development.
I write a lot about groups
working on X, Y or Z topic
related to health equity,
but from the perspective
of someone in a household,
it's a lot to take on
and it has to do with
the safety of their
environment, as you said.
So thank you for that.
So Mesfin, I'd love for you to expand now,
kind of even further
on the human experience
of health inequities because
I know you deal with this
day in and day out and
health equity is very much
at the center of your work,
the populations that you serve at IRC
often lack access to health services.
So, I wonder if you can
expand on the barriers
to access it come up in your work
and what that looks like
on an individual level.
- Yeah. Thanks.
Yeah, absolutely.
I think that is one of
the challenge of all time
in terms of equitable access to health.
When I think of this I
always go back to the 2008
report by that of the commission on
social determinant of health,
which probably be one of the
most articulate document,
what are the condition
that actually create health inequity?
And I think failure to address that
is what is leading us to
different health outcomes.
And that's true for refugees,
that is true for people
in low income countries
or true for people in
high-income countries.
So when it comes to refugees
and population affected by conflict,
these are the people who
are the most vulnerable,
either directly impacted by disaster
or running for their
life because of conflict.
And even that is growing
because of climate change.
And I think that is a
growing issue that we see
and it's was looking at the numbers,
number tells a story.
In 2021, nearly 235 million globally
get humanitarian aid.
That is one in 33 people
of the global population.
So that is like before the pandemic,
that was like 172 million,
which was like a jumped by a 100 million.
So this pandemic actually has hit hard
even those populations
who have the little means
to cope and as well as survive the impact
of pandemic or disease.
So the barrier to access to
health has multiple factors.
And one is resource
despite the growing number
of refugees and internally
displaced maybe a fall
85% of them live in low
and middle income countries
who have also limited the
resources to provide healthcare
for their whole population.
So that creates a huge strain
when you talk about refugees,
what comes on the media and
the headline is probably,
refugee in the U.S or
perhaps maybe a few migration
in Europe who have the
means actually to handle it.
But not to forget that 85% of them
are hosted by countries like Uganda,
Ethiopia, or Pakistan.
So, understanding the
need is a starting point.
Of course, the humanitarian system
has been generous in terms
of providing the resource,
but it has not been able to
match with the growing need.
Today, for population we need
direct humanitarian assistance which is
under the UN OCHA mandate,
only 36% of the needs are met
as of September, last month.
And which means that
people are basically living
in a situation where
there is no much resource
actually to provide the
care that they need.
And the other thing is these
places are characterized
by conflict in a way that
health facilities are damaged
or destroyed.
And healthcare workers are killed.
The safeguarding for health coalition
who regularly monitor report in 2020
that attack on healthcare
system has grown.
So in a way that when all these situations
are compounding and even the
little resource available
actually cannot be
accessed by the population.
And that is the kind of situation
people are experiencing.
So perhaps maybe this reporting
might under count even
the really number of attacks
to healthcare workers
even much larger than
what's already reported.
And of course, the other issue
is that refugees by nature,
there are people who are
running for their lives.
They are marginalized and
there is no political incentive
for countries that have
tried to provide protection
unless they have expressed
policy to support
or host refugees.
And also this politically divisive point.
You remember the Peacock
European refugee crisis
from Syria, a German
Chancellor plead to receive
one million Syrian refugees.
And we remember how
she received a backlash
for that commitment.
So, really including refugees doesn't gain
you electoral votes.
And as a result,
these are people who
are being marginalized,
not necessarily included in
the national response plan.
And when it come to COVID today,
many national plans don't
include the refugees
in the COVID vaccination rollout.
That's why COVAX has
created what is called
humanitarian buffer stock,
which is to meet those
population who may not be
otherwise included by
the national government.
And I think, I can go into the policies
and the number of people who ratified
even the UN convention for refugee,
as well as the additional protocol,
which provides the legal
mandate for countries
to provide protection
and as well as a kind of
assistance that refugees
can expect from government.
But not every country has a
signatory to those convention.
As a result, the population are left
at the mercy of humanitarian
assistance and kindness,
not necessarily that people
who have a right to claim.
- Great points.
Thank you so much.
I wanna pick up on one thing you said,
which you mentioned climate change,
and in terms of the urgency for action,
I'm glad you mentioned
that because that's gonna
only worsen these health equity challenges
and really increase
that urgency for action.
I wanna pick up on a theme that came up
throughout some of your remarks,
and that's whether we've
kind of talked about
what are these challenges when
it comes to health equity.
In terms of the path forward,
and as I said, at the outset,
the kinds of partnerships needed
to tackle these challenges.
One thing that that came
up a couple of times,
Sunil mentioned it,
Pascaline mentioned it,
is this idea of whether top-down works,
whether top-down is needed,
and there seems to be maybe
some disagreement on that,
which I think is actually interesting
in terms of having a discussion here.
And Mesfin, you just mentioned policy,
policy being critical and
a challenge you're facing
when it comes to addressing health equity.
So, let's talk about that for a moment
and a reminder to our audience,
keep those questions coming in on Q&A,
because I certainly
have a lot of questions,
but I wanna hear yours.
But we'd love to just get your thoughts,
any reactions you have on how
top-down has or hasn't worked
in your work on whether
a historical perspective
and economics perspective,
a policy and practice perspective.
I think that'd be an interesting topic
to just hear thoughts on.
So, Mesfin, I saw you
on mute, please jump in.
- Sure. Just in a couple
of points from me.
I mean, it depends on the
issue we are dealing of course,
there are room for both top down
as well as bottom up.
And I think, we need to be very clear
when we have a global
pandemic, like COVID,
we do need whole of society response.
And that includes communities,
national government,
as well as the global
system need to function,
including the UN system,
as well as a pharmaceutical
and all of the international system.
But unfortunately some of the system
are not efficient to respond to pandemic.
If you look at access to technology,
which is a critical for vaccine
and we have a system
that basically protect
access to technology through
the World Trade Organization,
intellectual property related agreement,
and it's not flexible.
And it also give undue
influence for people with
high-income countries,
not to make the system work
for equitable access to technology.
So, we should recognize
those inefficiencies
in the system that may not be deploying
the kind of assistance we need to respond.
But at the same time,
if you look at access
to vaccine and demand
that's where addressing misinformation,
engaging communities from the outset
and creating really an
enabling environment
where even the limited available
resource can be taken up.
So I would think that we
need to pick our tools
in the right way.
And I'm not in favor of one way
works better than the other,
but it depends on the situation
that we are dealing. Thanks.
- Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
Go ahead, Sunil.
- I think it was probably
unhelpful on my part
at the beginning to sort of frame it
as top down versus bottom up.
That is often how this is
kind of framed as a problem.
I think you know clearly
there are moments when,
depending on the scale of the problem,
and I think this does come down to scale.
There are different kinds of
challenges to health equity
that operate on very,
very different scales.
And we probably need to
sort of deal with them well.
A global pandemic on
the one hand and perhaps
much more localized kinds
of challenges on the other.
I think one of the questions
historically speaking is,
it's undoubted that top-down
campaigns or interventions
have very often had rapid
and effective results.
What we often find is that
those aren't sustained.
And I think that's where
the kind of multilayered
or multi-level sort of intervention
that Dr. Mesfin is talking about,
I think becomes very important.
After the initial impact,
talk about the disease
eradication campaigns of the 1950s,
initially there were
tremendously successful,
particularly against malaria,
but then partly because of
the sort of vertical structure
of those campaigns there was very often
the sort of diminishing returns to that.
And then I think environmental challenges
also come into this.
I wanted to sort of jump
in and ask, Pascaline
very interesting what
you were saying about
how geography matters and you keen
to sort of bring that back in.
I wonder if there are
insights from your work
about how countries in the Global South
which face similar
environmental conditions
then have very different trajectories
when it comes to health outcomes.
I mean, have you found that
there are sort of particular
so that it's not just the environment,
if the environmental conditions
or the propensity to certain
kinds of tropical diseases
are shared, do you nevertheless see
significant divergence
between different countries
as a result of the kinds
of policy interventions
that are made and which ones
are sort of effective there?
- I know and I wanted to jump in earlier.
So that's something we
should make sure that
to give us a mic.
Very quickly the dividends
that are comparing things
across countries is something that I think
we try to not do too
much because we know that
there are so many things
that can come into play.
So what I can tell you for
sure that within a country,
there is a clear correlation in terms of
health outcomes and the environment
that people face depending on
the ability to fight disease.
But of course, when you move
out of infectious diseases
and move out of things that
are very much driven by
the environment, there is an opportunity
and there is opportunity
in the health system,
there's opportunity in
access to health insurance,
in governance.
And that matters about for
whether the health workers
are gonna be well trained
and well motivated
and present.
So there's definitely a lot
of things that can be done
on their side.
And I think a lot of the
research has been focused on that
because it's kind of like
easier to think about
this approaches and to
work on these approaches
with individual governments,
new organizations,
because as Emanuelle said before,
it's very context specific.
So it's very hard to be
prescriptive and say,
"This is how you're gonna improve
or strengthen your health system.
It's really depends on the context."
And so doing this localized
work to make progress,
I think is it's been at least in my field
people are, "So this is possible.
So let's do that."
I just wanna say, there's a ceiling
to where we can go with that.
And on the larger environmental
stuff we need global effort.
- Just building on that for a second,
I mentioned earlier the Robert
Wood Johnson Foundation,
one interesting role I've
seen philanthropy play
is not just directly funding
work to address health equity,
but trying to highlight what
are some of those exemplars,
kind of building on Sunil's question
like despite some similar challenges
that different geographies might face,
there have been better
outcomes in this place,
and why is that?
And funding research on why
and sharing that research
to inform work in other contexts.
But, as Anne-Emanuelle, said earlier
contexts are quite different
and context matters.
So, I do wanna bring you in though,
'cause I know you had a
comment to make earlier.
- Yeah. Yeah.
It's not just that context matters,
it's politics and power that matter.
And I think those elements
have been under-emphasized
in the conversation this far.
Even if we're looking at
the difference between
healthcare equity and health equity,
we see this playing out
in very, very patent ways.
And so important as it is looking at
the symptoms or the end game,
the horrific situation of refugees
or so-called neglected diseases.
What we should be doing is asking
who is doing the neglecting, why and how?
After all trypanosomiasis
was not neglected
in the late 19th and early 20th century
by German and British
and other colonial powers
rather it was a huge threat
to territorial expansion
and acquisition, right?
So how and why certain health
conditions become more or less
important under particular
contexts at the global level,
and then where politics both
local and global play out.
And Sunil mentioned at the
outset of change in the 1970s,
but really this change was coming,
starting with decolonization in the 1950s
the BANJAN Conference and
a non-aligned movement
and the largest, the G-77,
the largest political grouping
within the United nations
that was able to push forward the concept
and ideally the approach
of a new international economic order.
So, how is it and why is it
that power is distributed so unequally?
So yes, the trips agreement and adherence
toward a huge issue in terms
of vaccine access, right?
But then the question is
how is it that the WTO
gets set up under whose influence, right?
And why are the rules
of the game so uneven
and so unfair in terms
of Europe has plenty
and North America have plenty
of subsidies for agriculture
and this has prevented
for Global South countries
who are not permitted to
have tariffs and so on.
So I think what we need to do
getting back to this health
and healthcare equity situation
is think through what the
structural determinants
or societal determination
of health as (indistinct)
and other Latin American social
medicine scholars put it.
And thinks through not
just what the factors are,
but what are the processes
and the rules of the game
and the power wielding that takes place.
The refugee situation at
bottom needs to be addressed
by addressing militarism, right?
And the fact that the
five permanent members
of the security council are
the largest arms exporters'
in the world.
It is a massive problem
that needs priority now.
You could say,
"Well, you've got a
situation on the ground,
how can you deal quickly
with structural issues?"
But we've been saying this for
decades and decades, right?
So, if not now when, right?
It is time and the fact
that so many have suffered
in such a great extent, and of course,
far greater extent from
COVID-19 in countries
with a huge asymmetries economic, social,
political asymmetries is a wake up call,
but certainly nothing new.
And so, I think it
behooves us all who work
in the larger global development field
really to be constantly
pushing at all ends.
And certainly on these structural factors
less they be placed in the
background as they typically are.
- I totally agree.
So let's bring those structural
factors to the foreground,
any reactions to what
Anna-Emanuelle just said.
We've had these conversations before,
but is the conversation
any different this time
in terms of the power and politics at play
when it comes to health and equity,
healthcare and equity?
You might wanna jump in.
Go ahead, Pascaline.
- So, I think deep down I
agree with Anne-Emanuelle
but at the same time it
makes me to give this comment
as pessimistic when I
think about the fact that,
okay, we are not gonna make any progress
if we don't change all
this structural problem,
I feel like it's gonna
have even one extra layer
of I already have a saying,
it's hard to think about getting agreement
to fix the environment.
If on top of that, we have
to bring in the monetary.
I just feel like people
say it's not happening
and there's just give up.
So, I wanna find room for
progress in a very short run,
but then there's always this tension,
like how do we make
progress in the short run
without forgetting to also
deal with these deep issues
that are so important.
I hear you, Anne-Emanuelle
I just feel like
do you see any hope for
a change on those fronts?
- Mesfin, you wanna jump in?
- Yeah, sure.
This make couple of thoughts.
I mean, when you look at the problem,
I think Anne-Emanuelle
has came to the picture.
You may feel like we are
paralyzed, what can you do?
I do believe there are
effort to address this,
when it comes to developmental in equity,
I mean, we have seen, for example,
how the MGD helps to
address child mortality
and maternal mortality.
And we'll move to the SDG with a mantra
of leaving no one behind.
That was tested during the pandemic,
actually what we mean
leaving nobody behind
when you are rolling out the vaccine
actually we have left everybody behind.
So in a way, I think we have to translate
this high level of rhetoric
into actionable plan
and implementation.
And there are a couple of efforts
to bring the humanitarian development,
peace building initiative
through what's called
a Humanitarian-Development-Piece-Nexus,
recognizing that these are not dichotomy
that exist in parallel
it's actually the same countries
that are going through
different level of fragility
and also countries affected by conflict
and also the same countries where we think
we should be doing development aid.
So in a way, how do you
bring the actor together
in a way that we can
address the root causes?
Not only just sending humanitarian aid
when people are starting to move.
So, and again, when it comes to health,
the pandemic has told us
that we need to invest
in public health infrastructure
and public health infrastructure
is not something that is
appealing to private sector.
And this is where
government needs to invest
on disease surveillance.
Probably that's not
what the private sector
would be interested to invest.
So in a way I think, see trading where
government has a role to play.
I think that role has to be
enforced through accountability
and also we need to measure and
show where there is progress
so that people can see what's
working, what's not working.
And translating this broad mantra
about how this health coverage
or leaving no one behind.
What does it mean in practical sense
when you are doing either vaccination
or when you are dealing with disease
or any of the health
issues that we are dealing.
So, I do believe that there is a way,
but I think what is
missing in many ways is
lack of political wheel.
And of course, unless you
have a democratic system
where electorate can
hold leaders accountable,
unfortunately, that's a rhetoric
which may not be necessarily translated,
but I think we need to measure and show
where this is happening and probably
from the countries who are doing better.
- Absolutely.
Go ahead.
- I was just going to say,
the idea is not to feel despondent.
In fact, it's an enormous privilege
to be able to feel despondent
as opposed to needing
to take action day to day.
I think what's crucial is understanding
how the global order, the global
political economy operates.
And then think through,
as Mesfin was suggesting,
what are some of the leavers, right?
And perhaps some of the best leavers are
why not a campaign to ultimately put
humanitarian organizations
out of business,
all due respect, so
that we don't need them
in a few years, right?
So that we have a system where
it's safe to live in Sudan,
and there's a redistribution
of income and resources
so that everyone has a decent housing
and decent education and
piped water and paved roads,
and full employment and
good employment, right?
So that we don't have these
hugely inequitable effects
and impacts on the most
oppressed groups of people.
So, I do think we need
to use our own positions
of privilege to speak out and
to point to these connections
and to go beyond, you
mentioned partnerships,
I really worry about
public private partnerships
because the private sector and certainly
the corporate sector in the
business of maximizing profits,
not in the business of
improving social conditions.
So, I think one needs
to be quite cautious.
And in that and in regard of partnerships,
which unfortunately the
STGs are emphasizing
and also seek to support
true democratic movements
and efforts and there's
been so much intervention
certainly in the Cold War,
but in other time periods,
when people's uprising for a new form
of accountable government,
and the U.S or other forces have come in
and nipped those efforts often
very violently in the bud.
So, again, big issues, but
not ones that we can ignore.
- Absolutely.
And I think this is
resonating with the audience.
I'm gonna share a comment
from the audience,
and maybe we can kind of gear it
into the form of a question,
but this attendee says,
"Thank you, Anne-Emannuelle for addressing
the power dynamics that influence health.
I'm very interested in the
intersection of health equity
and economics equity can not
be achieved until root causes,
colonialism racism,
unfair trade practices,
et cetera are addressed."
So that's just a comment
to give you a sense
of where at least one
member of our audience
is standing and seeing these issues.
I have some specific
questions I wanna dive into
and I wanna bring in
more from the audience,
but I wanna give space for any panelists
to jump with reactions, Sunil.
- Yeah. If I might just pick up
to develop the conversation
and including that interesting comment
from our audience member.
I'm gonna pick up on
something, Mesfin said,
which was the question of political will
and particularly the question
of what political means
in different kinds of political system.
One of the things that's always puzzled,
I think many of us who work
on health in South Asia
is how rarely health or health equity
have been major political
issues, even in India,
even in the context of regular
democratic competition,
things might be changing in India,
but let's bracket that for a minute.
Some parts of India,
this is also profoundly context specific,
there some parts of
India where governments
perhaps do fall over questions of health.
But by and large, that
has not been the case
that never been the case in
India since independence.
I'm not sure I have an answer to why
I've been thinking
about this for 20 years.
And I'm not really sure what it is
whereby in certain societies.
And I think Anne-Emanuelle,
your Latin American examples
are probably better ones there.
There has been mass
mobilization for health
coming from kind of upsurge
of democratic demand.
And there are places where
that hasn't happened.
And I just wanted to
put that on the table,
'cause I don't have answers to it,
but it is something that
has often puzzled me
must have been mentioned political will.
I think that's true, not just at the level
of the permanent members, current accounts
and the global governments,
but it also in a sense that
continues all the way down
even to the level of local government.
Where is it and when is
it that health equity
to use just the topic
of our discussion today
become something people fight for.
- Anne-Emanuelle, do you
have a reaction to that?
- Well, I was just gonna
say I think in South Asia,
they're the classic examples of Kerala,
the state of Kerala in
Southern India and Sri Lanka.
And so in the case of Sri Lanka,
a free universal, health
free the point of service,
universal healthcare system
that developed quite quickly
in the post-colonial
period and was fought for
and struggled for and exists
to a certain extent to this day.
I mean, it's being ratcheted
down through another force
that we haven't discussed,
which is the neoliberal
phase of global capitalism.
But, in the case of
Kerala it's so interesting
at times there've been
communist governments,
at times, not,
but the public support for
universal public health care
and education and housing
supports and so on is so strong
that even when the communists
are elected out of office
and another party is in power,
those issues remain on the table.
So, political will doesn't
simply come from politicians,
but it comes from those who are holding
as was said by Mesfin holding
politicians accountable
and also seeing what's possible, right?
Once that's tasted, then
the demands also rise
to a great extent.
I mean, I think we're
seeing that in Brazil
with the uprising against
Bolsonaro went in prior decades,
there's this creation of a fantastic,
a single healthcare system
and enormous social
investments and family wages
and so on that would
enable 40 million people
to be lifted out of poverty and so on.
And so people are reacting against that
and people in the streets.
So I do think it happens and
that including in South Asia,
not withstanding repressive
governments at times
and including now in India.
- I think you're absolutely
right, Anne-Emanuelle.
The point is more that Kerala in Sri Lanka
has such outliers in South Asia.
The question is why is it happening there?
To some extent, but nevertheless,
I mean, I think that's why
they're so interesting I think,
and there has been so much
sort of study what it is
about those two particular contexts.
And I think there are many
other examples around the world,
which I take optimism to some extent
that there have been repeated
sort of mobilizations
to hold the powers that be accountable
in relation to health.
- I wanna bring in a question
and this is something I'm
personally very interested in.
So hopefully audiences is as well.
But when we talk about leavers
for short-term progress,
even as we are addressing
these larger structural issues
that need addressing.
I cover innovation and
technology quite a bit,
and at least perhaps this
is an over-hyped space,
but digital is often
brought up as something that
could advance health equity.
It's also possibly
something that can worsen
health inequities because
not everyone for example
has access to broadband or smartphones.
But I did just wanna bring
up the role of digital.
I'm curious if the panelists
have reactions to that.
I know Anne-Emanuelle, for example,
you did some work on
whether digital technology
can address health inequities,
within and across countries.
And you concluded that
it can be useful tool,
but only under certain conditions.
So I wonder if you can just quickly expand
on what are those conditions,
and then I'd love to hear if
other panelists have reactions
on how that's come up in your work.
- Sure.
Well, you can't consider technology
divorced from social and
political conditions.
So it's not just the
(indistinct) drops down.
I mean, even if you had,
well we have a supposed
malaria vaccine now,
although it's really an
immune booster, but anyway,
we'll leave that aside.
Even if you had that, right?
This quick fix, what would happen then
to all of the efforts to
improve housing stock, right?
So that would end up
generating further inequities.
And then of course, who would be reached,
who wouldn't be reached and so on.
So I also think it's crucial,
especially with current day technology
to think through every step
of the commodity change.
So we are using digital devices constantly
without taking into account the thousands
of child artisanal miners
in the Democratic Republic of Congo
who were abused, mistreated,
exposed to cobalt in the mining process,
et cetera, et cetera,
not to mention every other
step in the commodity chain.
So we tend to kind of put technology
in this very decontextualized box
and, yes, we certainly
knew our interactions
are all shaped by technology,
but technology is also shaped
by the very power structures
that we've been talking about today.
I mean, who owns technological companies?
What's the role of metal mining?
I come from a country, Canada,
that has a heinous record human
rights and ill health record
in terms of its mining
involvement in Latin America,
it's extractive industries
in Latin America.
So I think it's really morally
and really analytically
bereft to not consider
the role of technology, to
talk about digital technology
and equity without considering
all of these implications.
So, it could be a useful tool,
but when it's embedded in policies
that redistribute power and resources
and do not concentrate harms,
which technology absolutely does.
- Good points on technology things.
I should definitely keep
in mind in my reporting.
I love your point on not putting it
in a decontextualized box.
So I don't mean to do that,
but any other reactions
to the role it might play
while considering that
complexity go ahead, Mesfin.
- Yeah, I think technology
has a huge problem
is in terms of addressing health inequity,
especially in Southern
Sub-Saharan Africa, for example,
is a place I know well
that how much actually
mobile technology has thrust
movement in people's life,
whether it's a mobile
payment, for example,
access to cash for people who are
not traditionally connected
to the mainstream banking system.
So, access information of course,
it has to be regulated.
It has to be in an onwards
that's understandable
by the local community.
And there should be some
level of digital literacy
as well that go with it.
It can be harmful as it is useful it is.
And we have seen how
misinformation kind of spread
very fast through social media
and all of those networks,
but at the same time, the same platform
can be a cause for good cause.
So, I mean, it has a lot of potential
and in humanitarian settings,
this is one of the area
where access to information
is actually as vital as
the life saving as it is
like access to food.
I recall during the Syria
crisis earlier days,
even for people where to seek asylum
and knowing their legal rights
and what is the safest place
to be and for children.
So all these kinds of emotions
are lifesaving for people
when they're on the move.
So I do think technology
has enormous potential,
but as Anne-Emanuelle said
it has to be regulated
in a way that is used and
it can also cause harm
if it is not proper to use or utilize.
So, in the place where I work
it's taking off addressing
many of the issue
that is related to health inequity.
- Other thoughts on technology?
Otherwise I certainly
have other questions.
Go ahead, Pascaline.
- I just want to add one
area where it can be useful,
which is, did you see
any early warning system
and actually knowing when
there is an epidemic starting
like Ebola even COVID
has been extremely useful
to be able to kind of have a sense of like
where there is more or
less people being infected.
And technology can
definitely help with that
with obviously all the drawbacks
that that means also monitoring people,
and there's like the big brother civilians
is a term that can be interpreted
very negatively or very
positively, whether or not
you're just surveilling people
or surveilling the visitors.
So I'm not saying that
this is necessarily always
a weight tool, but in some
context it shows like,
I think it's between contexts
where the health system in
may not be strong enough yet
for people to feel that they can trust
during an Ebola crisis, if I
go to the healthcare system,
am I gonna get Ebola,
whatever I'm gonna be able
to communicate information
about their own symptoms
through a phone, for
example, would be a great way
to help deal with crisis.
So that's one extra area where
I think it could be useful,
but I also wanna say,
I don't think it's (indistinct)
I got a phone call where Silicon valley,
like every student comes and says,
"Hey, I got this new app.
That's gonna like solve
every problem on the planet."
And I'm like,
"No, I strongly doubt that."
So I tend to have like an
outside technology point of view,
just as a reaction to the average person
around campus here.
But so I just wanna say
there are a lot of areas
where I think technology
is not gonna get us there.
And I wanna bring us back
to comment I made earlier
about the fact that they
are just like some diseases
that we just don't yet have tools for.
And malaria is one of them.
And when it comes to vaccines,
there is now some hope
that there is a vaccine
that may be partially effective.
And the question is how
do we make sure that
this is all out widely
as quickly as possible.
- I wanna come back to
each just very quickly
and I hate to make you respond
in about 30 seconds or so.
But if you can, that would be ideal
'cause I do wanna bring
in all your perspectives
one more time on this question of,
this is something Pascaline mentioned
as we were getting ready for this call.
She mentioned that over the years,
she's seen several openings
where there is a possibility
for action to address health inequity,
but then those moments come and go.
And I wonder if you're optimistic
that this moment might be any different.
And if it is to be different,
if real progress is to be
made, what needs to happen?
So just quickly coming
back to each of you,
how might this moment be different
if you're at all optimistic,
it can be and what needs to happen?
Pascaline, can we start with you?
- So, I mean, I just said
malaria vaccine as an example.
Recently I saw an article by the CDG
that I got very unhappy
with because it said,
"Look, let's think twice
about this vaccine,
is not as cost effective as other stuff."
And it was like,
"Oh, it's $200 per daily
compared to like 60
for something else."
And I'm like, "$200 for
daily, there's a bit here,
this is left here."
It's nothing like in the U.S
we spent like thousands of
virus per days, every time.
So it is super cost-effective
and we just have to
move beyond just saying,
"There's not enough
money and we have to go
for the really, really,
really, really cheap stuff."
We should have more
money available for that.
And I think there's an
opening there because
everybody here has seen what it means
to be in an environment
where you are afraid
of getting a disease from
your neighbor all the time.
We know that we're willing
to make sacrifices,
to just like, get rid of damn COVID, okay.
Everybody has been doing that.
And now we can put ourselves
in the shoes of people
who have been living in-
- Pascaline, you've just cut out for me.
Can you hear us?
Okay, I'm gonna go ahead and bring Mesfin
and hopefully Pascaline connection
will improve in one moment.
- [Pascaline] For a year and a half.
- Pascaline, I'm so sorry your
signal's cutting out for me.
Your signal cut out for me right there.
But now I think we see
you, can you just wrap up,
we missed the last little
bit of what you said.
- Sorry, let's just move
on to the next panelist
Sorry about my bad connection.
- Oh, I was leaning in and so engaged
in what you were saying,
but I think I understand
where you were going with it.
And I think we understood you enough
to be able to build on that.
So, Mesfin, can we go to you next?
- Yeah, sure.
When it comes to the greatest
challenge of all time,
which we started with COVID-19 pandemic,
as well as added climate change.
As you know, everyone is talking about
the need for building back better,
but there is far too little attention
in terms of the disparity
in terms of access to power
and resource between high
and low income countries,
even the most fragile states.
So I do consider this as a blind spot
to addressing the root
causes of injustice,
whether it is vaccine
or humanitarian crisis.
So, overlooking those context
is a strategic era as well.
And I do think, if you want to be serious
about building back better probably,
for a world that we want to see
not the one we left behind.
We need to translate this
rhetoric into concrete action
and through an inclusive
governance system,
and which is accountable as well.
And the pandemic has taught us that
investment in public health
should be a public good,
that government should not
delegate this responsibility
to private sector.
And we need to look at the
whole health governance system,
including international health regulations
for disease pandemic reporting.
And so that really addressing those issues
that are paralyzing now
to have a better world.
I think we need to look at our governance
and accountability mechanism
to have a fair world.
- Thank you, Mesfin.
And we're coming close to the end of time,
but Anne-Emanuelle we would
love to hear your thoughts.
- Yeah so I agree with
Mesfin that power asymmetries
are the crucial issue of the day
and of many, many years, in fact.
And I wouldn't say optimistic, but hopeful
in a range of actions
that have taken place
in different parts of the world.
The so-called striketober in North America
attempts to unionize at Amazon in Edmonton
and here in Canada, even
though it failed in Alabama,
John Deere strikes, gig
worker strikes and so on
all of the revelations
about corporate capitalism
and so on extremely important.
And together with those worker uprisings,
there've been some notable
indigenous uprisings
up and down the America's for example.
I mean, Ecuadorean in
Cuenca passed a resolution,
a referendum for clean
water and kicking out
a Canadian mining company.
That's a huge form of resistance.
And I think something to be
hopeful for and build upon.
Likewise elections in Peru
and finally in Bolivia
overturning a repressive government
that was supported by North America.
So I think there are reasons
for some hope and that is in the context
of people's struggles, right?
Not in terms of experts
developing better technologies,
divorced from all of that.
- Thank you.
Sunil, how are you feeling
as we close this conversation
and how do we make sure that this moment
doesn't just come and go
in terms of an opportunity
to advance health equity?
- One thing I've taken
from this conversation
is the need for joined up thinking.
We didn't talk much about climate change.
That is very much been on my mind.
And I think thinking about the ways
in which new environmental
justice maps on to health equity
I think without that
I don't think anything
that we do will we will
succeed because in a sense,
I think that COVID devastating though
it has been relatively fleeting crisis
compared with the climate crisis.
And I think the ways
in which climate change
is sort of supercharges all
of these existing inequalities
is something that we
will have to confront.
I wouldn't say I'm
optimistic, but nevertheless,
I think, there are enough people
in particularly young
people all over the world
who are deeply about the climate crisis
to make me think that if
ever there's going to be
an opportunity to sort of
start to connect those dots,
this might be as good as it
gets for the next little while.
- Thank you, Sunil.
Well, thank you all so
much for joining us.
Apologies, we've been a
bit over on time there,
but there was a lot of
complexity to get into.
Again, this conversation
was part of a larger series,
the Yale Development Dialogues.
Our next event which
will focus on Afghanistan
will take place on Tuesday, November 16th.
So stay tuned for information on that.
Thank you again so much to our panelists,
to all of you for joining
and to our co-hosts,
Yale's Economic Growth Center,
Jackson Institute for Global
Affairs and History Department.
Till next time.